hey  you okay there jesus  i think i hurt someone this is  ed warren here with lorraine all right  let's get started  residents of brookfield were shocked  this afternoon by the broad daylight  murder of bruno sauls  the court accepts the existence of god  every time a witness swears to tell the  truth  i think it's about time they accept the  existence of the devil  whatever is going on whatever happened  that day that was not ernie  it's a witch's totem we think your  family was  cursed and that connection is still open  i'm only interested in reality  but i can see things that your people  can't  [Music]  something terrible happened here  a master satanist is not an adversary to  be taken likely  she's doing it again  she's reaching out to the darkness  lori you need to come back  is saving him worth everything you have  because that's what my ferry will cost  the raid  you